und jetzt wollen wir direkt in den
bundestag schon angela merkel wird sich
nun den fragen der parlamentarier
stellen
ich habe heute die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder sowie die
vorsitzenden der fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages und anschließend
auch die öffentlichkeit davon
unterrichtet dass sich heute vormittag
entschieden habe die notwendigen
verordnungen für die zusätzliche
sogenannte oster ruhe also die ruhetage
am gründonnerstag und karsamstag nicht
auf den weg zu bringen sondern sie zu
stoppen
ich möchte diese entscheidung auch hier
zu beginn dieser regierungsbefragung
noch einmal erläutern zunächst die idee
eines oster shutdowns war mit bester
absicht entworfen wurden
wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen die
dritte welle der pandemie in der wir uns
gerade befinden zu bremsen und
umzukehren
dennoch daran kann es keinen zweifel
geben war die idee der sogenannten oster
ruhe ein fehler
sie hatte ihre guten gründe war aber
jedenfalls in der kürze der zeit nicht
gut genug umsetzbar wenn sie überhaupt
jemals so umsetzbar ist dass aufwand und
nutzen in einem halbwegs vernünftigen
verhältnis stehen
viel zu viele fragen von der
lohnfortzahlung durch die ausgefallenen
arbeitsstunden bis zu der lage in den
geschäften und betrieben können das
haben die letzten 24 stunden gezeigt
jedenfalls in der kürze der zeit nicht
so gelöst werden wie es nötig wäre
und um auch ein zweites klipp und klar
zu sagen
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
denn am ende trage ich für alles die
letzte verantwortung das ist qua amt so
also auch für die am montag getroffene
entscheidung zur sogenannten oster ruhe
ein fehler muss als fehler benannt
werden
vor allem muss er korrigiert werden und
wenn möglich hat das noch rechtzeitig zu
geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich
gleichwohl weiß nicht natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung ausgelöst hat das
bedauere ich zutiefst und dafür bitte
ich auch von dieser stelle noch einmal
die bürgerinnen und bürger und auch sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen um
verzeihung
diese zusätzliche verunsicherung bedaure
ich umso mehr als wir um als wir uns und
dabei bleibt es leider mitten in der in
dieser schärfe
insbesondere durch die mutationen
ausgelösten dritten welle der pandemie
befinden
und ich möchte deshalb einmal mehr all
denen danken die mit ihrem verhalten
dazu beitragen die dritte welle mit der
tödlichen und ansteckenden mutation des
corona virus zu bremsen und zu stoppen
dazu bietet der beschluss vom montag mit
den ministerpräsidenten auch ohne die
sogenannte oster ruhe einen rahmen mit
der notbremse mit der möglichkeit von
regional zu entscheidenden ausgangs
begrenzungen und kontakt beschränkungen
mit dem ausbau des testens und natürlich
auch mit der sich immer weiter
verstärkenden impfkampagne
ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt wir
werden das virus gemeinsam besiegen
der weg ist hart und steinig ist von
erfolgen aber auch von fehlern und
rückschlägen gekennzeichnet
aber das virus wird seinen schrecken
verlieren
und bis dahin müssen wir mit allen
maßnahmen weiter alles daran setzen dass
unser gesundheitssystem der immensen
belastung standhält und zugleich die so
überaus großen folgen für wirtschaft
bildung kultur und für unser ganzes
zusammenleben aufgefangen werden dabei
danke ich allen die mir persönlich
genauso wie der bundesregierung
insgesamt auch heute wieder ihre
unterstützung angeboten haben
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
stehe jetzt für ihre fragen zur
verfügung